two other news now the head of the
Wagner mercenary group fighting
alongside the Russian military in
Ukraine is blaming authorities in Moscow
for slow progress in the war evgeny
priguration told reporters that Russia's
struggled to capture more territory as
being fueled by a monstrous bureaucracy
he added it could take months to capture
the Ukrainian town of buckmut
ation
the advances proceeding slower than what
we want why is the advance not fast
enough I think we could have taken
control of bakmut by the New Year if we
had not been hindered by monstrous
military bureaucracy and obstacles
created on a daily basis
a Samuel of Romani is an associate
fellow at the Royal United Services
Institute and author of the book Putin's
war on Ukraine Russia's campaign for
Global counter-revolution he joins us
live from Oxford thank you very much for
being on Al Jazeera first of all let's
start with priguration's statement
basically blaming Moscow for hindering
the fight what what do you make of that
well I don't think that's very
surprising that progression would lash
out at the military bureaucracy in this
manner he's been launching a shadow
conflict against the defense minister
sergeogyu and dates back to the war in
Syria it is back to 2016. and it's
really escalated over the past year with
him going public as the owner of the
Wagner group and Russia's military
having set back after setback so I think
that this is totally in line with his
public Persona over the course of the
past few years so this is basically
covering his own back for Wagner's
failure
I think it probably is because the water
group assembled an army of 50 000 troops
40 000 prisoners and ten thousand
mercenaries and all they have to show
for it in spite of heavy casualties is
the Takeover of cylindar and backup food
obviously was uh increasingly important
for the Russian campaign because they
gave them a critical victory in done yet
as well as access to Railways and
Logistics and even though progression
has tried to frame and reframe Russia's
goals as not necessarily being into
capturing the city but are creating a
stalemate that bled Ukrainian forces and
results from the deaths of Ukrainian
territorial Defense Forces or elite
corps that that narrative is not really
that convincing because Russia wants
victories in Dynasty and pagosians just
not delivering them as losing heavy
casual days in the process yeah
percussions previously accused the
Russian military of attempting to steal
victories from Wagner I mean he
obviously has a very fractitious
relationship with Russian military
commanders how does that help in the
fight for the Russians
well the thing is it cuts both ways
because there's a large section of the
Nationalist and conservative uh
nationalists inside Russia who may be
inclined to support the war on Telegram
and other information channels or even
participate in the world's combatants
who are very very frustrated with the
leadership I'm sure going to show you
and Valerie grasimov so that has been
useful in some ways for water group
Recruitment and raising for goshen's
profile as a financial politician should
he eventually decide to form a political
party or should he get involved in the
process but it also cuts the other way
because he's wrinkled so many members of
the Russian defense Ministry and the
crown lab as well as Regional Governors
like St Petersburg Governor Alexander
begloth now he's got a coalition against
him has now aimed at reigning in his
power and an early example of this was
the dismissal of circus circus it's
referred general for his
archesma and the most recent is a
Russian defense Ministry taking over
from Wagner as the recruiter of
prisoners which means that Wagner's
Manpower is going to keep decreasing
rather than increasing in the months
ahead yeah well he also said that Wagner
was not going to be tapping prisons in
Russia to fill its ranks and and even
warned the impact that that would have
an impact on the fighting I mean what
does that mean for Russia's chances in
bakmut
six
well I think that the uh chances in bad
food were heavily related to Manpower
and Manpower is a priority so conscripts
and prisoners it wasn't a superiority of
logistics or training or even that
matter equipment I mean numerically they
may have more artillery fire but Ukraine
is getting NATO class artillery coming
to the front lines so it was really a
question of uh overming Manpower and
accepting happy casual days to to
achieve a victory and uh without this it
means that the Russian administrative
defenses prisoners and conscripts and
the Russian military proper will have to
play a more important role so pragosian
might ultimately see uh victory in back
mode by victory in Back movie that was
not being driven by Wagner I'd be driven
by the Russian military and that really
isn't very good for his own personal
Ambitions okay what does that mean for
for the war in a wider context
well I think that obviously if uh
pregosian is sidelined relatively from
the command structure and from the
issues after a potential victory in back
mode it does mean a centralization of
the command so Valerie grasemap is now
the commander of the Armed Forces as
well as basically having experience in
tank warfare so he's involved in the
artillery making decisions as well as
basically being the head of uh having a
prominent role within the general staff
so that might lead to a more of a
coordinated uh strategy so higher level
commanders and low-level commanders to
be able to communicate more effectively
if command is centralized progressimov
has proven at least in the first year
the war to struggle to manage uh local
battalions and local military districts
so it might lead to a centralization
that improves the effectiveness of the
war or it might lead you just more of
the same him being unable to really
exert his authority and his uh titular
authority over the people on the ground
so it's really unclear at this point
what will happen okay thank you so much
we'll have to leave it there that is uh
Samuel Romani associate fellow at the
Royal United Services Institute thank
you
thank you very much